cours de sciences sociales aujourd'hui
les partis politiques
la définition d'un parti politique il
dépend du régime politique dans lequel
il s'inscrit dans un régime politique
démocratique et pluraliste
un parti politique est une structure
stable qui a pour objectif l'exercice du
pouvoir en se fondant sur une idéologie
et des modalités d'action clairement
définis il paraît évident que la
première fonction des partis politiques
est une finalité électorale c'est à dire
qu'ils vont se présenter à différents
scrutins en vue d'obtenir le plus de
suffrages de la part des lecteurs
évidemment certaines listes et certains
partis ne se présente qu'un certain type
d'élection mais à côté de cette évidence
d'autres fonctions sont remplies par les
partis politiques
tout d'abord ce sont des centres de
compétences exercer le pouvoir
qui plus est dans nos sociétés complexes
et parfois très difficile c est lors il
faut se baser sur des équipes d'experts
qui sont animés par la même volonté de
réussir au sein de ce parti à imposer
une vision de la société et certains
solution à côté de ce centre de
compétences très pratique
le parti politique est aussi un centre
d'études un laboratoire d'idées
d'ailleurs tous les grands partis en
belgique s'appuie sur un département
propre qui vise à vraiment faire
fonctionner la machine idéologique du
parti pour le parti socialiste on citera
l'institut emile vandervelde et pour le
mouvement réformateur mahdi le mrc
l'institut jean gol qui se charge ici de
d'élaborer différentes idées bien sûr
les autres partis ont également leurs
structures et parfois on va voir émerger
certaines initiatives comme des
universités d'été ou deux universités
populaires qui permette à chacun à
chaque électeur à chaque sympathisant du
parti où chaque membre du parti d'
apporter sa petite pierre à l'édifice
idéologie
de la structure le parti politique est
aussi un nid guillon et d'idéologique et
identitaire c'est à dire que certaines
personnes vont définir leur propre
identité par rapport à leur
positionnement politique par rapport à
un parti ou par rapport à un autre
ça peut être une adhésion positive c'est
à dire que quelqu'un va se revendiquer
d'un parti à moi j'ai toujours voté pour
ce parti là ils sont vraiment et partage
mes idées ce qui est assez cocasse c'est
que quand on compare parfois la
déclaration d'un individu par rapport
aux idées ou solutions qu'il préconise
on va voir qui aura un décalage entre le
parti qu'il soutient et le parti qui
soutient les idées qu'il défend
ça peut être aussi un choix par défaut
puisque on pourrait dire comme c'est
parfois le cas en france
moi je ne voterai jamais pour un parti
d'extrême droite
et en ce sens on se définit comme
démocrate ou en tout cas en opposition
avec ce type de parcours
enfin le parti politique est aussi une
structure de sélection du personnel
politique c'est à dire que si un certain
moment où vous voulez vous voulez être
élu à certains niveaux de pouvoir il
vous faudra il vous faudra d'abord
escale et gravir les différents échelons
d'un parti politique il est en effet
très difficile de créer un nouveau parti
et de se faire élire dans ce parti
petite parenthèse qui nous permettra
d'aller plus loin dans un régime
démocratique le pouvoir traquer
structuré de cette manière c'est à dire
qu'on a le peuple qui va élire des
représentants au sein d'un pouvoir
législatif
ce pouvoir législatif va lui même
choisir est contrôlé à bourgoin
l'exécutif c'est de pouvoir sont eux
mêmes leur action est elle même complété
par un troisième pouvoir le pouvoir
judiciaire totalement indépendant de
deux premiers dans nos têtes
grâce il ya certaines dérives comme la
particratie la particratie si vous vous
référez au slide deux précédents mais
c'est vraiment un déplacement du pouvoir
du pouvoir législatif vers les parties
c'est à dire que les assemblées
législatives les parlements vont perdre
au fil du temps un petit peu de leur
influence et de leur pouvoir au
détriment des partis ce sont les parties
vraiment qu'ils vont donner le la de la
politique du moment
ils vont choisir les individus à placer
sur les listes et qui vont finalement
noyauté véritablement les arcanes du
pouvoir
évidemment il ya d'autres dérives qu'on
peut connaître au sein de différents
partis d'abord l'apparition d'une caste
si vous suivez parfois les débats
télévisés en france vous verrez que
parfois on parle de la gauche caviar
voilà de cette gauche du parti
socialiste proche de françois hollande
qui est déconnecté des réalités donc le
parti en lui même s'il est si
fonctionnent trop en autarcie s'ils
fonctionnent trop sur lui-même sans
regarder ce qui se passe dans la société
réelle
ben va être apparentée à une caste aussi
nous avons la possibilité de voir
apparaître des dérives clientélistes
c'est à dire qu'il faudra à ce moment-là
adhéré au parti pour pourvoir accès à
certains privilèges ou en tout cas
certains services qui ne devrait pas
être réservée aux seuls membres du parti
par exemple de logements sociaux qui ne
seront attribués aux candidats d'un
certain parti où certaines fonctions
dans des administrations qui ne seront
attribués qu'aux membres d'un certain
parti
évidemment si on pense aux affaires qui
ont touché évidemment le ps aucun parti
n'est exempt de ces différentes dérives
lorsqu'on parle de politique on en
revient toujours au clivage gauche
droite qui permet vraiment de structurer
l'offre politique un parti de gauche
au niveau économique voudra une
intervention plus importante de l'état
qu'un parti de droite voudra que l'état
c'est face à certains moments pour
laisser la place aux marchés et à
l'initiative privée
au niveau social un parti de gauche
soutiendra la solidarité le partage
l'égalité c'est à dire
il y aura une redistribution des
ressources qui permettra à chacun
d'avoir une égalité ne fut-ce que des
chances pour mener sa vie
à droite on privilégiera la liberté et
la responsabilité de chacun
la préférence à gauche 20 pour des
mécanismes universels
c'est à dire qu'on voudra toujours
dépassé les nationalismes et les
patriotisme pour aller vraiment vers un
universalisme à droite il y aura
toujours un esprit beaucoup plus
patriote chez certains passent de droite
enfin d'un niveau sociétal pour certains
thèmes de société comme par exemple la
nazis le mariage de couples homosexuels
on sera toujours beaucoup plus gros
progressif à gauche progressiste pardon
à gauche qu'à droite ou là certains
partis en tout cas seront conservateurs
sur ces questions éthiques
bien sûr ce clivage gauche droite est un
modèle simpliste qui se pose sur une
réalité complexe il ya beaucoup de
combinaisons possibles
on peut avoir des partis qui sont très à
droite économiquement mais finalement
très progressiste sur leur ligne éthique
sur les questions par exemple
l'euthanasie ou le mariage pour tous il
ya bien sûr différents courants sein des
partis si on prend l'exemple d'un parti
comme le r il y à des personnalités qui
se considèrent plus libérale mais très
progressiste tandis que d'autres comme
par exemple la ligne delà de ce texte
voilà de denis ducarme déjà fait une
galant sur certains thèmes comme
l'immigration vont être beaucoup plus
dur
évidemment ce que disent les partis
c'est la théorie et dans la pratique ils
ont parfois une politique qui est bien
plus différente que ce qu'est ce que ce
qu'ils avouent on va prendre le cas du
par exemple du ps qui dans le
gouvernement fédéral précédent même s'il
a parfois un programme très progressiste
et très à gauche mais finalement va
mener par pour différentes raisons
évidemment
une politique plus à droite qu'elle ne
devrait être si elle si le parti suivait
son programme aussi on a dans de
nombreux pays surtout là où le scrutin
le permet des partis centristes qu'ils
vont faire un petit peu le mix entre les
deux en belgique évidemment le parti qui
est au centre c'est le cdh parti qui est
à gauche économiquement enfin plus à
gauche au centre gauche au niveau
économique mais qui sur des questions
sociétales va être au centre droit enfin
il ya ici implique une simplification de
ce clivage gauche droite mais il ya bien
sûr l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
extrême gauche qui veut un tout à l'état
c'est à dire que l'initiative privée
soit réduite à sa plus simple expression
est vraiment une égalité au point de vue
des chances donc c'est à dire une
taxation une imposition plus importante
pour une redistribution plus importante
pour que chacun soit ego qui est le
minimum d'inégalités l'extrême droite
quant à elle privilégiera toujours les
nationaux par rapport aux étrangers qui
sont des produits étrangers et va être
très ferme évidemment sur les questions
d'immigration très autoritaire aussi
dans sa conception du pouvoir dans son
exercice du pouvoir
maintenant à l'heure actuelle on à
l'apparition de populisme qui font un
petit peu leur marché dans des idées de
gauche et de droite on aura l'extrême
droite française avec le virage marine
le pen qui va actuellement piocher
certaines idées à l'extrême gauche et
donc il est très difficile maintenant de
classer certain populisme modernes qui
sont extrémistes mais qui emprunte à la
fois à l'extrême droite traditionnelle
est à l'extrême gauche traditionnelle
voilà cet exposé d'ici terminé il était
sans doute très dense est assez complexe
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions aux
prochains cours pour éclaircir ces
différents points et nous nous
retrouverons tout de suite dans le petit
quiz
à bientôt